welcome back everybody I'm hanging out
with Jenna Lions give it
up so next year athletes from around the
world will gather in Paris for the 2024
Olympics my next guest is a retired
Olympian and World Champion in
fencing she's training the next
generation of Olympic hopefuls but
that's only part of her story more
impressive she's providing mentorship
and Leadership to underserved kids right
here in New York City please welcome
nazinga Prescott
everybody
hi here so we didn't plan this but you
fce as well you fenced in high school
right I fenc in high school let's but
mean I know but I didn't even know what
fencing really was in high school like
it wasn't like a thing like an
opportunity for me as a kid I never even
knew about it so I find that incredible
that you both did that I went to for
like a heartbeat a little a private
French school and then I transferred out
but they were very inde defensing and I
liked the
outfit it's pretty very sheap um but you
you grew up vincing right I did grow up
fencing so I grew up in Brooklyn I grew
up in an area of Brooklyn called
Flatlands which is right outside of flat
Bush predominantly Caribbean my mom
raised my sister and I and she always
put up put us in a lot of sports she's
very socially conscious and um really
believes in Black excellence and so uh
she learned about Peter Westbrook who is
a six-time Olympian and bronze medalist
at at 1984 and so um he was sending a
lot of inner city youth to the Olympics
and so she was like perfect going to
send my girls there and so we commuted
from Flatlands which is in outer
Brooklyn all the way up to chela
Manhattan um and as I was getting good
it was four or five times a week so it's
quite a commitment it was pretty
successful a super mom I have a super
mom bless my mommy she's so great and
you said she's a single Mama she's a
single mom oh my gosh holding all that
down and taking you to all those things
that's a lot right and from there I was
able to work with the Olympic coach
since I was 10 and that allowed me to
win World ch Championship medals go to
two Olympics and you know have a really
phenomenal fencing career um next year
I'll be in the Hall of Fame so that's
Prett oh gosh
congratulations that's
incredible an incredible journey fencing
has really changed my life a ton and
enabled a lot of opportunities so it's
and it builds I think for kids when you
find something I always say this on the
show but when you find something you're
good at and you feel good about and
special it gives you a different level
of confidence confidence right and you
can do can do can do yeah and you take
that with you everywhere so yeah that's
been it totally transfers over in other
parts of your life I I agree so explain
fencing because I had to do it like I
said for the voice one the time and I
was like I'm sorry what you want me to
what you know explain that if nobody
ever like heard of it which a lot of
people haven't like it's incredibly
technical um it's people call it
athletic chess it it's very physical um
but even more so than physical it's very
mental it's like strategy right it's
totally critical thinking analyzing
problem solving so there's like this
maze that you're constantly trying to
figure out the intricacies of how to
change this detail or that detail so
that you can battle your opponent and
you know come out Victorious so it's a
really amazing well-rounded sport um it
normally attracts a lot of affluent
people um prep schools Ivy League
schools that's why I never heard of it I
was like so it allowed me go to go to
Columbia I fence on Colombia's team and
um just opens a lot of doors and so you
can imagine it's quite expensive um and
so that makes it pretty exclusionary in
terms of geography finances um even
culturally it's pretty hard to like um
IM immerse a community in fencing when
historically it's been a predominately
white sport so that's that's the
background yeah that's like a rich
people sport where were like yeah I
played Polo I'm like okay I played
volleyball was like I don't like all the
public school things you do um well EXP
explain your organization like why is
this important to you right so I grew up
with this opportunity but I was an
anomaly in accessing that and so I
started the Prescot Institute for Sport
teamwork and education we started as
spening in the Park which is a summer
program and so we just I wanted to
increase access to the sport in my
community where I grew up um because I
did have that huge kind of burden of
traveling and so I always wanted to
bring it back with all the skill I
acquired over 20 plus years and um open
up those doors for the Youth in my
community the kid that was you yeah yes
for the kids that were me because I I
was the only one growing up who had that
and even just quality organized sports
are very expensive and where I grew up
it's not accessible and so that was just
always something I wanted to bring back
and put in my neighborhood so that
breaking down all those barriers for the
next generation and it gives you
confidence but it also um it keeps kids
out of trouble that's why my my mom you
know I was always in sports I was always
in theater I was always involved in
something and that's why yeah I hands
right out of trouble hands right and
it's productive outlet for them it's
productive you learn strong work ethic I
always tell people I had to learn how to
work hard right so that's what we teach
them we teach them to have strong
characters to be good leaders um to be
good people so we we heavily instill
Olympic values of Excellence friendship
and respect yeah in the program and just
hope to hope they'll they'll use it in
their in their next steps and they will
and they won't even know they're doing
it there are things that I was so
annoyed by when I was kid and I was like
uh why do I have to do this and then now
I'd see it in my work ethic you know you
didn't really see it when you were a kid
it pays it pays It Forward yeah agreed
all right joining us now are Julia and
Amy two of nzinga's fencing students
from her nonprofit school in Brooklyn
welcome to the show ladies
hi so I have to ask like what's what's
your favorite part of fencing my
favorite part in fencing is that I make
lots of friends and we go through things
and once I beat my brother he was a
little bit mad oh my God you just like
my kids that's amazing I love the
competition what about you my favorite
part of fencing is the fact that I get
to work with kids I can relate to and it
helps me balance being an school and
being an athlete yeah I love that too
like those
relationship so I I have to ask you this
I wanted to ask you minuto but how do
you afford the nonprofit like how do you
do this like it's a lot of money right
so the program is free for families so
equipment lessons classes um all of our
services for families are are free so we
depend on funders um individual funders
we get some funding from the the city
council so very thankful um some
corporate sponsors so I'm an employee at
ernston Young ey so they've been um very
supportive with the program allowing me
to work full- time on building it and
then um ballets Corporation has been
super helpful and then nonprofit like
women's sport Foundation has been really
incredible we're actually going to be
there later today um to an accept an
award so it's really Community effort um
where it's I'm very active and the
team's very active to find funding and
so we're not yet going National but
hopefully this year we'll go to the
Nationals and then from there it's
International so it's is the only thing
holding you back really the financial
part of it when you say National
financials like we all work very hard I
was the kid that went on scholarship to
anything in high school because we
didn't have money so this matters it it
really matter does change a person's
trajectory like their life exactly so
we're trying to give them the best and
they deserve the best so absolutely we
depend on the community all right well I
was thinking Emy you want to teach you
want to teach us like a move or
something I mean the sword's here I'm
here you're here of course okay let's do
it okay let's stand up you want to do
it I heard there's a specific way we're
supposed to get a sword is that right
well first things first you can never
have the tippy in the air right okay
because that's a safety Hazard so you
want to keep your tip down and I think
em knows how to hold the foil pretty
well so she can show you okay you want
to show okay so we're going to do the
advanced lunch so I'm going to put my
foot forward and then bring my other
foot then we put the pressure on my
other foot and you l o looks like a
workout e okay okay okay okay and heels
that's a plus that's all right that's
all right we're women we do it all the
time so what what about when do I get my
sword
when do I when do I get that are we
going to play with that we're not going
to play with that okay I want one I want
one I was like can I have one do you
have you grab it a certain way right yes
okay so grab it facing down it's called
a p well I'm the host I have to hand
them out yeah I was like here we go
there you go oh thank you I'm a good
host I'll grab one too okay okay okay so
you so you stand like this right and
your your foot is is perpendicular uh
yes you have to bend on oh sure okay oo
tell that looks good seems like a
workout and then you just
lunge uh you advance with one foot that
four and then you Lun and then you lunge
W nice I feel like I'm encoun on a ksto
I like it I like it this powerful I know
why yall like this I just just having it
in my hand alone I feel really good
about it um well I heard that hul you
have something you want to say to n
Zinger right yes I'd like to say that I
love you so much and I thank you for
everything You' done I love you too
[Applause]
a it's it's really cool what you're
doing for these kids it is really cool I
wasn't that's just not just lip service
literally people that helped with
scholarships to help me give me
opportunity as a reason why I'm here so
we we actually have something for I love
that so we actually have something for
you so radical fencing is an NYC based
fencing sport equipment company bringing
beautifully crafted products and
Innovative designs to fencing to
continue supporting peace they're
donating a $5,000 gift card just to help
help out with all the
equipment we love what you're doing
thank you for teaching me I can now
advance I like it I do I look at you you
were like I'm
ready she was automatic she was like
what before we go I want to give a quick
shout out to Maria our assistant
associate producer who brought us this
story she's actually one of our newest
team members as well as a fcer herself I
found out in a meeting so she helps uner
with peace great job Maria we love you I
love finding this out about
[Music]
[Applause]
you thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home